ciao questo io oggi ho uno slide molto
particolare da farvi vedere in più mi
serve il vostro aiuto perché io non
ricordo assolutamente niente di come ho
fatto questo slime perché praticamente
questo è uno degli slime che ho fatto in
video quindi l'ho fatto in uno dei miei
video solo che è successo qualcosa di
strano questo slime si è trasformato
trasformato tra virgolette è
praticamente non so come ma sono uscite
migliaia di bolle è praticamente esploso
non so come sia successo e non mi
ricordo assolutamente che slime sia
quindi voi che siete molto super bravi e
intelligenti e super attenti vi
ricordate sempre cerchiamo di capire in
quale video fatto questo e slime così
riesco anche a capire ingredienti sono
che l'hanno fatto esplodere così tanto
come me ne sono accorta ho aperto il
cassetto dell'islam in cui ci sono
praticamente anche faccio invidio
praticamente tranne qualcun altro che
magari faccio per conto mio
la challenge che forse avete già visto
che ho fatto con vitare quello lo slime
lo scambio lunghe i e stavano scegliendo
it is live quindi li stava un po
rivedendo tutta che ti lega se volete
vedere la mia colletta dell'italia che
cos'è questo slime non mi ricordo
assolutamente di aver fatto uno slam con
così tante bolle sicuramente è esploso
dopo perché guardate poi stavo guardando
meglio così allora
vi faccio vedere meglio i dettagli
quindi forse capite da dove viene questo
lo apriamo allora sotto a dei glitter
verdi che mi fa pensare forse era uno di
quegli spline bendata e so che si
accolla trasparente perché vedete non è
un tool bianca per me è abbastanza versa
la cosa che non capisco sono queste
stelline gialle perché sono quasi sicura
al cento per cento di non aver mai avuto
queste decorazioni stelline gialle poi
l'idea è come se qualcuno poi un
fantasma che c'è qua la via fatto di
nascosto l'abbia messa nel mio cassetto
motori e in questione del maledetto via
perché ho usato questo contenitore lungo
io non avremmo mai ho ridato contenitori
contenuti nei saperi l'islam
forse usando questi contenitori lunghi
le molle crescono del doppio o del
triplo per circolante allo studio di
così piccolo e le bolle sono quelli tipo
l'ottanta percento dello slime
incredibile comunque di man ha preso
allora nonché per curiosa è rimasto un
po numerate civili
addio sono tantissime le bolle o che ora
vi cambia inquadratura così l'avevo
detto ancora meglio un odore fortissimo
di schiuma da barba o gel da barba beh
sicuramente c'è se ci sono così tante
buone sicuramente c'è il gel da barba
troverà eccoci qua guardate un po quante
bolle ora immergiamo piano piano la mano
dentro e vediamo
sono posti che però è fighissimo sembra
zucchero filato
ho chiuso la finestra così sentite
meglio i rumori
e anche un po metallizzato non capiscono
per come ho fatto questo film
sì decisamente o vi faccio donna con la
trasparente non so se mischiata con
della colla bianca e ci sono dei glitter
claire t
e rimasto tettino è un pochetto
appiccicoso che ti motiva non forniremo
settore così guardata distilli n'è tanta
allora fa da aggiungere della soluzione
lenti perché è un po appiccicoso grazie
a dei suoni pazzeschi e ha un profumo
nissimo perché ho usato la colla
trasparente quella come si chiamava un
ricordo col nome francesco padre e sa
che fu di mandorla sentisse che suoni
[Applauso]
guardate quante volte ma siccome ma si
formano tantissime bolle
impazzisco per quello che voglio cercare
di capire in che i video le foto così so
che ingredienti ho messo che lui se
volete lo potete arrivare anche voi
comunque queste stelline ti giuro non mi
ricordo proprio aspettate forse ho
capito allora ora che le guardo meglio
non sono proprio stelline ma sono delle
sorta di perline con il buco per fare i
braccialetti
quindi se hanno il buchetto vuol dire
che ho usato il set di perline quello
barbie per fare i braccialetti quindi mi
ricordo che in un video
ho usato quel set di perline e mi sembra
che era un video in cui ero bendata o
non credevo ma non mi sono fatto in una
challenge però ora abbiamo già un po più
di indizi per indovinare con a nudo ho
fatto questo slimer ragazzi incredibile
il po king che fa questa squadra
che voto date da 1 a 10
questo slime per aspetto e per suoni
allora io perfetto vi do un sette e
mezzo giusto perché non mi piace il
colore bardolino lo sapete la
maledizione degli slum verbi però
persone di don indirizzi
assurdo rimarrei a giocare con questo
slime tutta la sera
non capisco perché il colore è così
scuro perché sento chiaramente l'odore
della colla trasparente però forse c'era
anche con bianca
non lo so vediamo chi riesce a
indovinare per primo da quale video
deriva questo times sono sicura che è un
video in cui era un bendata o c'era
qualche challenge del proprio per questo
che uno mi ricordo come cavolano fatto
perché ho usato anche queste berline
gialle e mi dicono di emergenza te
mentre air open data con quel luogo il
superfluo corso anche come fare due
placche allo stesso momento per ed
escono un po sorti mason tirate lo slime
e poi girate da una parte e dall'altra
per età e poi si sa fare
quindi hanno messa per i miei commenti
da dove esce fuori questo la juve che
diventa super bauli ora non rimettono il
nostro contenitore e mediaset continua a
crescere così tanto lo stesso mi piace
mi metto in un contenitore ancora più
lungo perché questi magari cresce ancora
di più ma non ho nessun contenitore più
lungo e quindi ma diletta benedetto
se vi piace se volete sentire altri
video a smr comunque sul fly magari se
volete video sono sull'aim a smr
fatemelo sapere nei commenti
scrivetemi tutta e ora mi lascia
alquanto cappelline su cui potete
cliccare per vedere i prossimi video se
volete vedere i miei altri timeline il
challenge e ora rimangono portato in
queste strade ma rilassarvi e giocarsi
sandri frey
[Musica]